In this video allow me to guide you on how to organize
Our data and
Preparation for our
Chapter Four
Given that we have surveyed
via face
To face
via manual
We don't go online
Survey or we don't use
Google forms
How can we
Recocompute our data
That we will no longer maneuver
So here we can use our accent
First we have to
Our variables
Based on our sot
And based on the data that we have
Through our
Instrument instrument
So for example
In our soup
We have
Asked about
The demographic
Profile of our
Response
And our and under
demographic
We have some profile
Variables such as sex
strand strand
The grade or the rating
So let's say you have asked for the
Challenges
Encountered
In writing
Research papers
Say that you have five
Indicators
For that
Specific s or p
What we will do
We have to include
The data
Of
Specific
Respondent
Per row in our excel
So
Let's say we have thirty
Respondent so we may have
One to thirty
That's a respondent
And each row
Represents
The answers
Or the data coming from each
Respondent
Now since later on we will be using
The spss and in our version of spss
He doesn't take words in the
Competition
We can assign a number
Say if the respondents
Sex is male
We make
Input One
And if the respondent is a female
We make input number two
The same with the strand is
We may designate a
Specific number four a
Specific strand of the respondent
Since the grade or the rating
It is already a number
So we can put their answer
And then for the indicators
What we will put here is
of the column
Corresponding to their answer
Didn't we have
Let's say you have four columns
And the first column
Represents for
Strongly agreed
Which is four
Then the second
Column is three
Or the agreed
And then the third
Column is two or
Disagree and the fourth
Column is one or
disagree
So say yours
Respondent number one
Check the first column
So here at
Let's excel what you will codify are four things
In this case
Respondent number one is male
Coming from
Strand number one
Of course we will assign a strand
For example
Mail respondent number one is
Coming from abm or strand number one
His rating is
Ninety five
At first
The chenekanya is first column
In the second
Indicator chenekanya is second column
The same goes for
Third and fourth
And fifth
Indicators
So how did you code the data to first
Responding
You will do the same until
Respondent number thirty
To count
The number of males
Response or
Female respondence or to count the number of
Response
Coming from each strand
Ash we can use that command is this
The command equals
Count
If
Count if
Open parenthesis
And then
Highlights
The volume
Only up to number thirty
And then coma
Then input
The number
That represents
The group that you want to count
So since we want to count
The mail we may
Included one
Then close
Parenthesis and after
So in that case
There are actually twelves
There are twelves
Male responder
So we will do the same with women
So we have equals
Count if
Open parenthesis
And then
Highlights
The column
Up to number thirty
Coma now since we are
The female we may have
Included
Two and then close
Parenthesis
Enter so in this case
We know that there are
Eighteen
Female respondence
So we will do the same with per
Strand here
Okay so where are we going to use it?
Twelve
That number for male
And eighteen numbers for female
So of course we could use
This to present
Number of male and female
Response
Since we have
Statement of the
Problem
Referring to the demographic
Profile of the respondence in terms of sex
So later on
You may just get the
Percentage of
Twelve and
Eighteen
Out of thirty
Response
So how can we recompute the wated
Arithmetic mean
So since our data is already placed the four
Three two ones
We may just get the meaning per volume
Means
The wated arithmetic mean of
indicator number one is
Formula
And then here with auto samyung
Arrow down our iclick iclick
And then the average
So we may obtain here
Three point thirty
Therefore
The wicked arithmetic means for the first
The indicator is three points thirty
So to get
The wated arithmetic meme for the succeeding
Indicators
We made
Just drugs
Test to the right side
So this means
indicator number once one is three points thirty
Followed by three points forty three
Three point twenty
Three point thirteen
And two point fifty
So to get
The overall weight and arithmetic mean
We may just get
The average
Of these five
So highlight
Then
Overage
So our rated aritmatic mean is three point eleven
So using our legend
Says
This is our legend
If the pain one
It is three point twenty six to four point zero zero
Let's say we have
Strongly agreed
If it is
Two point fifty one
To three points twenty five
We have to agree
And then if it is one point
Seventy Six
To two points fifty
We may have this agreed
And if it is one point zero zero
To one point seventy five
ahmm the verbal
The description is
Strongly
disagree
So if the octane witted arithmetic ministry point thirty
Our verbal
The description is
Strongly agreed
For this one
This is also the case
Strongly agreed
Three point twenty
I only agree
Three point thirteen is agreed
Fifty is two points
disagree
For our
Overall one three point eleven
The verbal
The description will be agreed
Together with theirs
Verbal
Description
How about we have him
Interpreted in our
Chapter Four
So we may start with the overall one
Then mentioned
The three highest
And the
Two lowest